[Musique]
bonjour et merci de nous retrouver dans
le 7-8 choisir toutes vos idées sorties
dans le département et tout de suite le
sommaire de ce numéro la ferme de gally
organise le samedi 22 avril à ces
universités du goût une troisième
édition sur le thème le temps et le bout
allant du miel mini chef de projet
offerte de yannick nous parlera du
programme de la musique des machines et
de la fourrure c'est le spectacle
permanent de l'artiste florence rochelle
l'exposition est à découvrir à elancourt
nous irons pu faire un tour et dans le
cadre de cette exposition justement une
installation interactive est également
mis en place une boîte à danser que
mélanie nôtre est entré dans une autre
rendez-vous junior et jusqu'à fin mai
l'exposition consacrée à robert doisneau
est toujours à visiter à versailles
plus connu pour avoir capturé le baiser
de l'hôtel de ville en 1950 le
photographe a également travaillé comme
reporter mondain pour le magazine vogue
l'exposition a été mise en place par ses
deux filles elles seront à l'espace
riches au samedi 22 avril à 15 heures
pour échanger avec le public et
dédicacer le livre de l'exposition
en mars elle nous avait parlé du lien
que robert doisneau entretenait avec la
rédactrice en chef de vogue de l'époque
écoutez ils sont entendus dès le départ
vraiment et là c'était une telle
complicité que lens 8
quand il a signé un deuxième contre 1
elle n'accompagnait toujours il n'ya pas
une photo pouvait se faire sans qu'on
soit ensemble ça a certainement beaucoup
pda sont les ans dans ce milieu là parce
qu'il était effectivement accompagné de
nous complice absolue qui elles étaient
issus de ce milieu là et qui donc
elle avait les codes ça a beaucoup
ajouté dans cette dans cette possibilité
de
d'excellence du travail on peut montrer
aujourd'hui samedi 22 avril c'est
également le début de l'exposition des
40 ans du club photo de
voisins-le-bretonneux jusqu'au 8 mai à
l'espace de covile les visiteurs
pourront découvrir le travail des
adhérents du club 80 photos
sélectionnées par un jury réuni en cinq
thématiques architecture paysage macro
minimaliste et studio on écoute jean luc
detavernier l'un des membres du club
photo
le club compte cette année un peu moins
de 50 membres et il ya un peu plus de la
moitié des membres qui ont eu des photos
de sélectionner et pour qu'il n'y ait
pas de frustration vis-à-vis des autres
membres
chacun était libre également de proposer
trois photos de sujets peut-être
différent des sujets sélectionnés par le
jury et qui tourne rond sur un
ordinateur également dans l'expo pour un
truc la durée de l'expo aux fermes de
gally les universités du goût reviennent
pour une troisième édition samedi 22
avril toute une journée consacrée au
goût à comment manger et comment prendre
le temps de manger avec nous amandine
gulli et le mini des fermes de gally
pour nous dévoiler le programme bonjour
amandine bonjean caming et le programme
justement durant cette journée il y aura
des conférences et des rencontres
exactement des conférences des tables
rondes des témoignages d'entrepreneurs
est également un déjeuner vous
partagerez avec les intervenants un
moment convivial avec des petites
touches sur le sujet que des jeunes est
accessible à tous a réservé le déjeuner
était la réserve est effectivement été
longtemps le site internet de forme de
guérilla
alors un petit mot sur les intervenants
du coup que vous amenez alors qu'ils
sont il ya des chercheurs exactement des
chercheurs en sociologie neurologie des
historiens du goût qui vont nous parler
des saisons comme du temps que l'on
passé à table avant contrairement à
aujourd'hui on passe de moins en moins
de temps à table
comme exemple de témoignages de
conférences n'y aurait à ne pas manquer
alors à ne pas manquer c'est l'ensemble
de la journée parce qu'elle va être très
intéressante comme les autres années
comme témoignage un petit peu
particulier on suit depuis trois ans
fabrice et conquis éleveurs laitiers et
qui a qui a monté un une nouvelle
manière de commercialiser le lait avec
des éleveurs et son souhait c'est une
nouvelle forme de coopération qui
s'appelle de nous à vous et qui qui
fonctionne très bien donc nous on a eu
la première année quand il travaillait
sur le projet la deuxième année quand il
l'a lancée et cette année je pense que
il va passer à la phase de développement
qui va nous dévoiler tout ça et parmi le
chercheur vous accueillez des
spécialistes également est exactement
[Musique]
comment ça commence dès le matin ça sert
vers 10 heures c'est ça à 10 heures on
commence avec claude fischler qui va
nous parler du mangeur et donc du temps
passé à table avec un regard
sociologique
ensuite on va passer sur une conférence
avec florent quellier qui est historien
et qui lui va nous parler du temps de
l'ancien régime et du temps passé à
table pendant l'ancien régime
on a le frère mari pack qui lui va nous
faire le lien entre le temps biologique
et l'otan spirituel puisque une
produisait du vin précédemment donc il
va nous parler de son expérience et ont
clôturé la matinée avec jacques lépine
qui a inventé une fourchette qui
justement nous permet de réguler le
temps de que l'on passe à table et de ne
pas manger trop et après ça se
poursuivre tout l'après midi mais alors
on a bien compris effectivement à
thématique c'est le temps de cette
troisième édition
alors quel est le lien en fait entre le
temps et le goût pourquoi avoir choisi
cette thématique
parce que le temps c'est une dimension
centrale pour le goût puisque on peut
parler aussi bien du temps qu'il fait
donc des saisons du temps que l'on va
passer à produire vous prenez l'exemple
d'une bouchée de pain que con mais très
peu de temps avalé en fait la graine de
blé qui a servi à produire la farine qui
elle-même a servi à produire le le pain
il ya de fortes chances que ça fasse un
an et demi qu'elle ait été mise en terre
donc quand on prend conscience de de ça
je pense que on passe à un repas un
moment pour le repas qui est un peu
différent et ce à deux journées des
universités du coup ça s'inscrit plus
largement dans votre programme pour
fêter les
50 ans de votre magasin 50 week-ends
thématiques sont prévues tout au long de
l'année
exactement donc donc ça fait 50 ans
maintenant que le magasin des fermes de
gally à saint cyr l'école est ouvert et
on a on essaye d'organiser donc chaque
week-end un sujet particulier dans l'est
dans les cinq thématiques fa ne pas
manquer cette année on a commencé avec
la fête des abeilles qui était fin mars
on continue à fêter les abeilles tu t'en
aller parce qu'on a mis en place en fait
en partenariat avec une entreprise belge
en biomonitoring donc on scanne au
territoire grâce aux abeilles pour
s'assurer qu'elles ont bien à manger
tout au long de l'année donc on va faire
quatre prélèvements dans nos ruches à
quatre moments de l'année pour pour
s'assurer que qu'elles vont bien voir de
quoi se nourrir et donc éviter leur
mortalité et les maladies dans les
prochaines semaines alors que ce qui est
dans les prochaines semaines pour le 14
mai on va fêter le jardin puisque on
lance une mini mini ferme urbaine dans
notre magasin au fond de la pépinière où
là on va on va monter un jardin
collaboratif donc tout le monde peut
venir s'exercer au jardin et prendre des
conseils des personnes qui sont qui sont
autour de ce jardin pour apprendre à
faire un jardin chez soi avec
différentes techniques du plus petit a
une dimension plus grande
ensuite on aura la fête du goût comme
chaque année le 9 octobre
si je ne dis pas de bêtises toutes les
informations qu'on retrouve sur cet
insecte le mans donc la fête du goût en
accueillent tous nos producteurs
l'année dernière on a accueilli 50 50
producteurs donc je pense que cette
année ce sera ce sera pareil et on
organise aussi un grand buffet champêtre
à cette occasion on a ensuite la fête de
la citrouille qui a lieu au moment
d'halloween ou là par an et enfin
viennent creuser des citrouilles et
enfin dans l'ue dans le dernier
événement a pas manqué ce sera noël
puisque on va ouvrir la ferme du père
noël
forcément on vous dira merci beaucoup
aux amandinois guljé le midi 2 est
revenu sur notre plateau donc on le
rappelle les universités du goût sont
prévues
samedi 22 avril et s'ils voulaient
manquer pas d'inquiétude de nombreux
autres week-ends festifs sont organisés
merci encore amandine guyane midi et
tout et tous les détails sont à
retrouver sur le site internet des
fermes de gally
merci et à elancourt la troisième
exposition de la saison à sociaux arts
et sciences vient de débuter
l'artiste florence rochelle nous fait
découvrir son univers constitué de
machines de moteurs de fourrure et de
musique plonger sur les images de
michael et demi d'euros
[Musique]
une batterie recouverte de poils une
danse hypnotique en veste rose un autre
monde imaginé par l'artiste florence
rochelle il ya quelque chose qui renvoie
une sorte d'animal qu'on serait en train
de rentrer en train d'opérer et donc ces
instruments étaient transformés avec de
la fourrure
et puis ils sont augmentés de
voilà ils sont mécanisées il ya quelque
chose qui m'intrigue qui m'intéressent
qui m'amuse dans celle de rendre compte
de manière poétique au coeur de la
chapelle de la commanderie des templiers
l'exposition se veut un spectacle
permanent un laboratoire d'expériences
des créations réalisées spécialement en
harmonie avec le lieu
c'est un lieu qui me touchent et j'avais
envie
d'abord que
ce que j montrait
entre en résonance est en relation avec
ce lieu est en même temps le laisse le
laisse visible je n'avais pas envie de
de masquer ou de de mettre trop de
choses qui voilà qui aurait
ray fait qu'on ne verrait plus la
chapelle une rencontre entre sciences de
l'ingénieur et création artistique à
découvrir jusqu en juillet et pour les
plus patients un message en morse et de
déchiffrer dans le rythme de la batterie
[Musique]
et en parallèle de cette exposition la
commanderie des templiers accueille un
dispositif numérique où vous êtes
invités à danser et c'est mélanie poker
qui va nous en parler bonjour mais
l'ennemi bonjour camille alors c'est
flou 612 c'est son nom s'était imaginé
par daniel larrieu chorégraphe français
et c'est une installation à danser comme
vous l'avez dit camille un projet
chorégraphique faits par les enfants
avec les élèves de l'école pierre budin
à paris mais c'est surtout fait pour les
enfants de 6 à 12 ans plus exactement
d'ailleurs c'est de là que vient le 612
je laisse à nos scooters qui est
danseuse ou la compagnie de daniel
larrieu vous en dit un peu plus elle
était au micro de mikael davud d'euros
daniel larrieu l'a conçu vraiment dans
un espace de liberté c'est-à-dire que
quand les enfants dans cette boîte n'ont
aucune consigne
ils peuvent danser ils peuvent marcher
courir bouger ou alors ils peuvent juste
contempler le décor donc c'est vraiment
un espace de liberté pour eux mais alors
comment ça fonctionne en fait il ya des
capteurs 48 au total qui vont réagir aux
mouvements
ces capteurs vont notamment modifier la
lumière et la musique alors dans la
boîte on trouve une toile de 17 mètres
avec des décors de jungle et imaginaire
des failles et des végétaux
principalement et chaque lumière fait
apparaître de nouveaux éléments sur la
toile c'est ça qui est le plus
impressionnant
regardez cet extrait
[Musique]
le
pourtant telle aventure flow 612 et
pourquoi pas se découvrir des talents de
danseur rendez-vous à la commanderie des
templiers
jusqu'au 4 mai merci mélanie nous avoir
présenté ce dispositif et on passe
maintenant à notre agenda tout le
week-end les producteurs vont démontrer
leur savoir-faire à voisins le
bretonneux la ville et le centre alfred
de vigny organisent leur nouvelle
édition du marché des terroirs
vous avez jusqu'à dimanche 13h pour en
profiter et un nouveau trampoline parc a
ouvert ses portes à maurepas corbin jump
propose de nombreuses activités du dunk
offrit jump l'occasion de s'amuser en
famille et c'est la fin de ce set 8
loisirs je vous remercie de nous avoir
suivis je vous retrouve vendredi
prochain pour un nouveau numéro et je
vous souhaite un excellent week end
[Musique]